Gabe Feldman of Tulane University Sports
Law Program who conferred upon me an
honorary degree years ago but neglected
to sign it now here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you Gabe I'm doing great
how are you not was I correct in in
setting all of that up was anything
incorrect in that Gabe that was entirely
correct and your degree is not official
it's kind of like the yellow line right
it's kind of like the old line on the
field kind of like that so walk me
through it what happened yesterday Gabe
well yesterday was relatively simple as
far as these legal proceedings go the
Fifth Circuit in a two-to-one vote said
that the Players Association has filed
their case too early and they had to
wait for the arbitration proceeding to
finish they had to wait for held
Henderson to hand down his opinion and
they didn't and that means that the
court just did not have the asari or the
jurisdiction to hear the case and so the
Fifth Circuit dismissed the case saying
Players Association you went to early
court didn't have the right to hear it
they ordered the district court to
dismiss the case which means right now
the only case is now pending in New York
where the NFL has filed one tender said
did finalized his award so there's a
case pending in New York and ridiculous
a Lea could take one of two options
primarily is he could appeal this Fifth
Circuit decision and when use a term
you've heard before and I know you love
it you could make a non bonk appeal an
appeal to the entire Fifth Circuit to
ask them to review this three-judge
panel decision and overturn it to
reinstate the the injunction to
eventually essentially put the
suspension back on hold for he could
file for the plumeria injunction or a
temporary restraining order in New York
basically follow the same exact papers
with some minor changes in New York
asking the New York judge to put a hold
on that suspension that's where we are
all right so look just a couple things I
want to ask you all off the bat let's go
back to what happened in in August that
led to them to be able to get on the
field or September here
didn't I hear was it one of the lawyers
for zekiel Eliot who said that you did
when a bulldozers coming for the house
you don't wait for it to knock the house
down you try and stop the bulldozer and
I guess the judge in Texas bought that
argument that was now overturned
essentially right the judge but two out
of three judges in the Fifth Circuit
said it wasn't clear that the house was
going to be bulldoze and you do in fact
have to wait for the house custody
bulldoze because we can't review the
destruction to the house until the house
is destroyed okay then then secondly
then now it strikes me here that we are
just seeing a repeat of every single one
of these player discipline issues
between the NFL and the Players
Association that it no longer matters
who it is or the team you could just
fill in the blanks and it's all about
the power of the Commissioner and the
NFL Players Association trying to poke
holes in it am i incorrect or incorrect
in this game oh absolutely correct
whether it's Adrian Peterson Tom Brady
now is equal to Elliott this is the same
underlying battle how much power does
the commissioner have what rights do the
players have and what rights to the
court have to interfere with this
process and the fact that over and over
right and the fact that the Players
Association and now it's zekiel Elliott
not Tom Brady not Adrian Peterson but
now Ezekiel Elliott is gonna have to
find or will eventually find a judge
that agrees with them and then the NFL
will find an appeals court that agrees
with them and eventually Zeek like Brady
is gonna run out of options where he's
either got to go to the Supreme Court or
he's got to basically take his
suspension am I correct in that
assumption to game well that's the way
it played out for agent Peterson and Tom
Brady where they wanted the district
court level and then lost at the Court
of Appeals and then they decided not to
go up to the Supreme Court doesn't
necessarily mean it's going to play out
that way here it could be that the Court
of Appeals does side with the Players
Association and says that this process
was just fundamentally unfair and though
the collective bargain agreement gives
great power to the commissioner there
are limits and exceeded the limits here
through all the things we talked
throughout this process not allowing T
Roberts to testify not giving over her
notes not allowing the accuser to
testify all of those things the court of
appeals could say made the process
unfair and as echolalia will be
irreparably harmed if he's forced to
service suspension so it's not a
foregone conclusion that Elliot will
lose this case the other players before
him have lost the case on appeal but
that doesn't mean that we're gonna get
the same results here okay so then the
ultimate question is gave Development
Director Tulane sports law when when
fast does this all go down for cowboys
fans were sitting here wondering if
their season is now going down the drain
with a six-game suspension right here
right now okay
bye weeks obviously helps them a little
more time.i if they appeal to the Fifth
Circuit Han dong the Fifth Circuit could
rule on that very quickly the Fifth
Circuit only accepts about 3% of those
appeals so it's a long shot to even get
that case granted to be heard and then
even if it's heard you still have to win
the case so that could happen relatively
quickly that could happen within a
matter of a week it could happen before
next Sunday or she could file in New
York and ask for an emergency tiara or
emergency injunction to stop the
suspension again just like he did in
Texas that hearing could be granted
early next week that decision could
happen middle of next week it could all
happen before next week's game but again
one issue is the timing can he get it
done quickly enough but just as
important if not more important is will
the decision go down his way but it
could in theory happen quickly enough to
keep him on the field but you're gonna
have to get another federal judge to
agree with judgment over in Texas the
state of process was unfair and that
he's entitled to injunction those are
difficult things to do one judge already
did it so it's certainly possible
another judge okay so then because I
have been with you through lockout and
conversations like this for years now
Gabe I am going to instead of asking you
what you think will happen I will tell
you what I think will happen and you
tell me if that's likelihood is going to
take place and
that is the case you have to sign you
have to sign the honorary degree gave me
okay Gabe and and what do I get if
you're wrong I don't know just an
attaboy
okay all right and it's worth nothing
okay how about this here we go that he
will do something to try and stop it I
don't know what it is but it won't
happen in time for the week seven game
against the 49ers so he'll have to miss
that so that's one game and then he'll
have to wait for that decision have
happened between games weeks seven and
eight and he will have to sit there and
say do I just pull the plug and take the
five games right here or he will then
get that relief right now that will last
the rest of the season and I'll play the
rest of the year what do you think Gabe
that's possible I don't I don't hate
that predictions I think the a push
forward with it right now they could get
a decision before we accept which would
destroy your prediction okay but if not
it's possible and it may be that they
make that decision now that Elliot says
I'm tired of the distraction I just want
to get the six hands out of the way and
let me get back on the field for the end
of the season but remember not only did
Elliot have that interest in playing
those games for getting those suspension
out of the way but the Players
Association also has that broader battle
going on with the league that they don't
want to give in it not just about Elliot
anymore just like al isn't just about
Tom Brady or deflated footballs it's
about fairness to the next player and
giving these players a fair hearing
before whether it's the Commissioner or
held Henderson or ideally a neutral
arbitrator so again it's not just for
cowboys fans it's about getting a lien
on the field for the Players Association
it's about him getting on the field and
getting protection for the next
suspension the next discipline alright
so in fact so in 30 seconds do you think
Zeek does play a game again this year
Gabe what do you think I think he does I
think he does play again this year well
obviously or after the six in December
or do you think let's put it this way
does he play a game in October I think
there is a better chance that he plays a
game in October than he had
before the season started I think that
case law that decision by judgment may
be persuasive to report in New York so I
think table says should be feeling more
optimistic than might otherwise be but
it's still the odds are stacked against
okay that's why you're the director of
Tulane sports law and I have a
non-operative degree from it so thank
you Gabe always appreciate it my
pleasure it's always great chatting at
sports log I follow Gabe he knows what's
what the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience if you liked
some of that get some more of that on
the Rich Eisen show app follow all the
information you see right here on the
Rich Eisen show